hallo wollte es ist endlich soweit am
heutigen tage wenn die drei pakete die
von mir ausgewählt wurden von mir
persönlich zu den leuten gebracht und
was machen als allererstes natürlich als
allererstes rufen wir die erst mal an
und sagen hey leute die erste die leute
anrufen die erste glückliche heißt let's
kollegen
am montag
für halo sie haben in meinem shop was
bestellt und ich habe ja quasi zum
gewinnspiel gemacht dass drei bestellung
von mir persönlich vorbeigebracht werden
und ja er hat gewonnen
also ich bringe das persönlich vorbei
also ich pack das quasi ins auto und
wird es dann einfach zu ihnen vor die
haustür fahren war es unter s p würde
mich kennen ich habe jetzt sofort zeit
also theoretisch könnte ich jetzt
einfach überfahren
ok top alles datenbanken laufen weg ist
es okay wenn max auch mit kommt also
mein bruder ok super alles da
ungewohnte situation bestimmt aber das
würde ich endlich alle eingepackt die
letzten tage die welt vor allem
sebastian gestern bis nachts um vier
noch paket report ist verrückt was denn
auch wenn das ist alles selbst noch in
ordnung wenn ich vielleicht bei gericht
nicht direkt aus ca
ja klar ist ein lustiger moment also ich
glaube wir haben weder mein bruder noch
ich haben jemals die situation dass ihr
tatsächlich beim zuschauer zu hause
waren also du bist ja der erste zudem
jetzt kommt ja wir fangen spielen zu
zwei weiteren und aber ich find's cool
also rat nur als schwester dieser witz
beide freudig erreicht was hat dich
ergänzte das ist in ordnung wenn mir ein
bild machen ist das ein anti wir können
und viele bilder machen wie du willst
gerne alle daher auf jeden fall was ihr
auch viele youtuber das schon hatten
dass beim zuschauer zu haben man trifft
sich zwar immer
so weit will nur in der staffel zu
fällen man sieht oder video das zuhause
von esther sammelte sagte kohl dass es
geklappt hat sich ja gut dann wobei wir
verabschieden uns unten in china mit der
china und schönen tag wieder auch schöne
feiertage schauen menschen grüßen hallo
sagen jahres entsteht
ich grüße meine besten freunde des
buches ist das denn nico war mega
geschält voll der coole vater die hatten
da um so ein richtig heimisch ist immer
alles war mit holz selbst geheizten
weihnachtsbaum der voll geil wir feiern
zu hause essen kannst du abend unsere
mutter macht schon richtig stress und
dann geht es weiter mit dem live stunden
später also wir haben quasi drei
gewinner wir haben jürgen wir haben
larissa und wir haben theresa und
theresa rufen jetzt mal einen schönen
tag
hallo grüß gott ich rufe an weil seine
frau teresa
in meinem shop was bestellt hat so
youtuber merching da ist es das okay
alles klar
hallo
ja gut gut
theresa anna julia ich ruf an weil du
die persönliche lieferung gewonnen hast
ja ich mache jetzt auf den weg zu teresa
das ganze ein bisschen länger gedauert
ich habe mich eigentlich für 8 uhr
angekündigt jetzt ist es schon 20 von
neun weil wir noch packen mussten wir
fahren morgen den urlaub mein vater kam
gerade vorbei jetzt aber alles ready und
wie viel los zu teresa aber eigentlich
müssen wir vor noch bei larissa anrufen
bei der dritten glücklichen im bunde mal
gucken ob diese noch erreichen ist war
eigentlich morgen früh schon wegfahren
ich hoffe ich erreicht hier noch schönen
guten tag mein name grüß gott hallo
sie haben eher in meinem shop esquinzo
playa was bestellt hast du wild bist du
larissa hast du bestellt cool
larissa ich wollte sagen du hast glück
gehabt denn du hast die persönliche
lieferung gewonnen nein es keine
verarsche dass man voller ernst ich
würde es jetzt quasi wie youtube
postbote machen und wenn es euch passt
heute abend noch vorbeikommen passt es
bei euch kein großes ding
ok sehr cool sehr cool okay da machen
wir es so ich mache kurz noch eine sache
und ruft dann in circa einer halben
stunde noch mal an
ein tiefer in größe ist klar sowieso
teresa ist und du wirst juliane wissen
jetzt hier bei julia teresa aber nämlich
die mutter habe ich vertauscht julia das
ganze ding gewonnen und du bist du
jemanden grüßen
ich würde für antonia bekannt auch ein
autogramm unterschrieben
super damit hat auch julias bekommen und
ich weiss weiter jetzt die letzte
bestellung des heutigen tages an larissa
aber eine menge umgeguckt heute mit der
lieferung geht mein job als aushilfs
weihnachtsmann zu ende und ich bin
richtig gespannt
es regiert
vega ums haus schleichen kann schlecht
erzogen leute ich noch nicht mal die
haus zu tun kannst es nur noch
verteidigt
[Musik]
drei tage später leute gerade in bella
das heißt mein akku einfach ausgegangen
aber wenn wir es auf den ganztag
zurückschauen fällt uns auf dass es mega
mega mega nice war erst merke was sagst
zum will komax wirkung richtig korrekt
nummer 2 theresa nicht reeser ihre
tochter julia auch mega cool und zu
guter letzt habe ich larissa besucht
heute alle chillige leute larissa ist
hat mir das hier mitgegeben schlappe
winterwochen mega korrekt von ihr aber
leute eine sache möchte ich noch sagen
und zwar hab ich mich zeitlich bei
dieser ganzen sache einfach ein bisschen
verkalkuliert warum morgen früh müssen
wir schon urlaub fahren um 10 uhr ihr
müsst handy wunder fand ich weiß das
leben ist hart leute aber wir fahren
morgen um 10 uhr laufen bis dann muss
alles fertig sein ich hatte heute so
viel zu tun ich muss wieder 90 paket zur
packstation bringen und deswegen hatte
ich einfach nicht mal so viel zeit für
den teil mit den persönlichen liefern
ich musste deswegen weil ich einfach nur
noch vier stunden hatte den persönlichen
weihnachtsmann zu spielen und die
päckchen hier weg zu bringen einfach
leute aus der nähe nehmen also leute die
jetzt nicht 1000 kilometer von mir
entfernt sind weil leute die sache ist
wenn ihr vier stunden nur noch zeit
haben die dinger weg zu bringen an drei
leute wird bisschen enden will jemand
herausführte tausend kilometer entfernt
ist das war so einfach ursprünglich
nicht geplant ursprünglich war geplant
dass ich auch lange strecken auf mich
nehme aber ich hab mich da zeitlich
einfach krass verkalkuliert wenn ich
jetzt sagen wir mal an nach münchen
gefahren wäre hätte ich nur nach münchen
hin fallen können wir nicht mehr zurück
fahren können und dann hätten die zwei
anderen leute gar nichts bekommen ich
wollte einfach nur offen mit euch sein
die so was einfach andernfalls muss so
sein es war eine geile sache an alle die
noch auf ihre lieferung warten
sorry leute auch bei euch kommt es auch
an um beim nächsten mal werden wir
einiges gelernt haben und es deutlich
besser machen diesem sinne auf heute
macht's gut